e
e e
we have any
Replacements uh I don't think so it
being 1 to 1:00 we'll call the finance
committee meeting to order the first
item on the agenda is a hearing on House
Bill 619 619 and I'll call upon the
sponsor representative Abel thank you
very much Mr chair um and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Karen Eble I repre I represent mayac
district 7 which is New London and
Newbury and I'm also here in my capacity
as chair of the state stakeholder group
The solid waste working group so um this
bill uh supports the appropriation of uh
a million dollars into the solid waste
management fund you may recall in the
last budget the um the state the
legislature saw fit to fund this program
um the house actually supported putting
$2 million into the fund ultimately it
was cut to a million which is where it
stands um and it's a matching grant
program for municipalities and for
businesses to uh do work in uh waste
aversion the other thing that we did in
the last uh budget was to revise the
language so that 50% % of the um of the
appropriation would be prioritized for
food waste
diversion um so one thing just to I mean
there's several things that we can talk
about but you know uh a couple of years
ago we um did adopt after a a 20year
Hiatus a new Solid Waste Management plan
and as a state we also adopted new Solid
Waste diversion goals we're trying to do
25% by weight diversion of solid waste
into landfills by 2030 and 45% by
2050 so food waste and one of the
reasons that we prioritized it um in in
the last budget um is it constitutes
between 25 and 30% of all weight that
goes into landfills now we all know that
landfills are a big topic around here
and um a new landfill isn't a popular
Prospect with either the governor or
vast numbers of our citizens and we also
know that Dees has said that from a
regional standpoint there may be a lack
of capacity but there certainly isn't
one in New Hampshire so we should try to
continue to preserve our uh landfill
capacity through waste diversion and
that's one of the things that this um
fund would help promote so as I noted um
our towns are really uh struggling with
trying to keep up on with all the
challenges presented by Waste Management
it can be expensive and helping towns
and cities through this grant program is
a great way to kick Kickstart food waste
diversion and other recycling activities
and it'll help to uh promote our planned
goals um it also is a is a business
promoter because there's a lot lot of
businesses that from local farms and I
think you all did get some testimony
from a local farmer who um is trying to
help with compost it's a great source of
income to them and they can turn it into
aable soil so our local farms are
interested in um assistance there are
smaller food waste collectors and
composters uh and then we can also try
to help to get food to food banks and
come companies uh that that have
anerobic
uh divest I mean
digestors so um I guess that is sort of
a a summary I wanted to say it's
interesting um New London actually my
town did a in have a uh composting
program they started about a year and a
half ago and I got the numbers from them
and if you can believe it 172 families
participate in the program and we
diverted 32 tons of food waste from the
landfill in 2024 so that helps with
tipping fees that also helps with um
Trucking I was talking to the public
works guy this morning it's like $700 a
load to uh to take all the trash up
there and I guess the last uh one last
thing I would say is that we know from
all our discussions about past
um last time uh landfills not only do
they sit there pretty much forever but
they also kick off a lot of leee
hundreds of millions of gallons leee
contains pasas and any number of other
uh terrible substances so the less that
we can put into landfills um it's all
good um I think that's it so i' uh be
happy to answer any question questions
about the about the fund I know that
there's a lot of uh people in the state
that are excited about the prospect of
getting some grant funding um I think I
don't want to speak for the department
but the department is certainly
interested in helping with waste
diversion um and it's really important
for our state to do that so um I'd happy
I'd be happy to take any uh any
questions thank you any questions from
the committee representative
lean thank you Mr chairman uh good
afternoon representative
evil so I was just quickly scanning
your uh letter that you gave us this
afternoon and I see that our tonnage
rates or the charges that are being
charged to the hallers are pretty
minimal I guess for the State of New
Hampshire versus if you look at at Rhode
Island and Connecticut Vermont and I you
mentioned that you're looking for about
a million dollars are there other
creative ways to raise money like having
a tipping fee for instance at these
facilities where the state would get you
know $5 or $10 per ton or would that
work sure well thank you for the
question um representative
Lehman we actually um I I chaired a
study committee about 5 years ago and we
talked quite a bit about this and we
talked about the about funding issues
and we all know with diminished uh
General funds um we do have to be more
creative about things I think I should
just say at the start so people
understand we we have about two million
tons of trash that goes into landfills
every year and about half of that is
from out of state so and a huge portion
of that is from Massachusetts so you
know hear a lot about not massing up New
Hampshire well that's one way of massing
up New Hampshire right there um and of
course when you have the landfills it
really is a forever kind of problem once
it's here it's here and many states in
fact I would say a good majority of
States actually have a search charge
that they add on to tipping fees so like
if somebody pays $60 a ton to deposit uh
uh a ton of landfill to put a ton into a
landfill there could be a dollar sear
charge on that there could be a $2
search charge on that um and that sech
charge in many states is actually used
to help fund recycling efforts um really
the the solid waste management fund idea
was not uh my creation uh that is
actually something that's used in many
many states and it's used by these sear
charges I did um or it's funded by these
sear charges I did give you some
information um in the
testimony um we don't charge a sirar
charge and we rely on General funds for
all for our Solid Waste activities and I
looked at other states just recently
Iowa actually charges
$425 a ton and it's been doing that
since the 80s North Carolina charged is
$2 Ohio charges $475 and Vermont has
charged $6 a ton since the dawn of time
so or maybe a little less than that so
just as a general matter if you think
about it and if we want to do good work
with our Solid Waste if we don't want to
have more landfills if we think that out
of state trash should maybe contribute
to some of the issues that we have here
by um by having their trash then one
alternative to funding a fund like this
is to at least talk about or or consider
this idea of a of a search charge and
I'd be um I'd be happy to talk to the
division uh more about that I I do want
to say that in 2021 we had a report the
average cost per ton for municipal waste
in Massachusetts to landfill is $122
um in Vermont the average was 116 in
Rhode Island it was 100 and New
Hampshire is 60 to 80 so even though our
costs are much lower than area landfills
um in the Northeast
region it's lower and plus we don't
charge a sarch charge at all so um I
appreciate the question and I think when
you're in a revenue situation like we
are lots of things should be at the
table on the table and we can be
creative about it representative McGuire
for a question and then representative
Cal thank you Mr chairman how many tons
per year are we talking about here well
I just happen to have the
statistic um the last the best
information that we have is uh
1,923 th000 total coming into the uh
total in the state 1.1 million ion in
state and we had about
825,000 out of state in tonnage and that
was as of the biannual report that was
um that was prepared by the department
um for as I say for 2022 I did double
check uh with the Department actually an
hour ago to see if we had more updated
numbers and they thought that it was
about the same the out of state may have
dropped just a little bit but that
that's basically the number so if you if
you think about it depending on the sech
charge um you know you could generate a
considerable amount of money and as I
say uh that's the way an awful lot of
States handle this thank you
representative camell for a question
thank you Mr chair um and thank you
representative for taking the question
um currently how much money is in the
fund and to date has any of the funding
has any other the money been used to uh
start the
initiative um thank you for the question
representative uh director whim is here
but um I will say unfortunately uh due
to uh processing time through the
Personnel department they weren't able
to uh get the position listed really
promptly um and so they're still in the
rul making process for the grant program
um they hope to have that done in the
next several months and then they can
start working on the Grant I think
though that the amount of money that's
in it is about $900,000
because part of the money was used to
defay the
employee yep representative Edwards for
a question uh thank you Mr chair I I
have a question on both ends of of the
of the middle of this um the first one
is I'm I'm trying to understand um
what it is going to be um expected of
families uh and I assume this isn't just
commercial food because 172 families
were involved do does a is a family
expected to take any uh food waste that
they have dump it into a special
container keep the com container
segregated like we used to with aluminum
cans and then take the food waste in
that canister and dump it into something
at the dump how how what does that
process look like inside a family home
okay um well I remember doing it with my
with my German parents when I was
growing up here my mother always had a
separate thing just for garbage or for
TR you know um food waste uh and that's
the way it is now so I I just want to
make sure from your from your question
um there's no requirement that that
people do this in New London it's an
optional thing and that's the way it is
in in most towns so um yeah I mean I
participate in the program the town
provided a bucket uh five gallon bucket
I just have it there um in in my kitchen
not too close to where I cook and uh and
I fill it up and when it's full I just
take it over to the transfer station
we've got totes there big totes you dump
the dump the food waste in there and
then once a week a a small growing
compost company called renewal compost
comes up and picks it up and takes it to
a farm in near your area Mr chair I'm
forgetting the name of it and they and
they compost it so that's what it looks
like for a family and um you know part
of the startup fee in New London for
instance is they bought the buckets that
they gave to people people all right may
I have a follow question okay so so my
dogs are my recycle system so they also
wash my plates before I put them into
the dishwasher just to gross everyone
out but um on the back end of this it
sounds like you already have there is an
example of compost companies and I'm
just wondering uh why we aren't
converting those contracts into uh money
to pay for this program the the this
waste does have some value to it and I
just want to know if we've thought
through what the state needs to do in
order to to to recognize the revenue
that could be associated with selling
that
waste I I think um for the most part
they're just farmers and they're using
it to augment their soil I mean I don't
think anybody is making Megabucks on
this I think and then for an anerobic
digestor it's a waste energy thing I'm
not sure I think
the I think that you would find that
there's not whole lot of money to be
raised there it would make more sense
that we consider uh a dollar or two per
ton on the trash that's lingering in our
uh land here mountains Hills and Dales
forever thank you where are the
questions from committee members
representative r thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you representative eel
so following on representative Edwards
line of questioning um the savings would
really lie with the municipality because
they would be
saving the cost of tonnage from the
diversion is that correct that would be
the goal yes and is followup Mr chair
would there would there be anything to
preclude a municipality from um
generating Revenue let's say from a food
compost
if if this let's say a town gets a grant
like this they're going to save on the
um diversion but could they also lower
their property taxes by creating a
revenue stream of compost that may be um
produced through a project it's
conceivable that they could I I think in
marac you have is it you have composting
we get free that's sludge I mean I I I
think the bottom line is here not to
look at the compost as a revenue
generator but to understand that by
diverting the food waste and also I mean
this can apply to to programs to do
better with
recycling um the idea is to not be
landfilling it to retain our capacity
and to do something better with our
trash I mean from my standpoint that's
about as yany a thing as a person could
do
further from the
committee Mr chairman repres Naval Linko
uh Rich alanco chesher 9 uh I have a
question that the 900,000 what the
estimate of a million bucks is based on
how how much you're going to expend
annually or what period of time is this
supposed to cover I know there are
startup costs which I assume the
$900,000
that's currently in the fund
goes a long way toward covering and then
there's some estimates of uh how how far
you expect the million bucks to go in
terms of the number of uh so what is the
the million bucks based
on uh it was uh not based on a lot like
a lot of Appropriations for a grant
program you put money into it in the
hopes that it's used to do the things
you want it to do but I think it's
really difficult ult to estimate how
long a million dollars would last I mean
we could you could ask the department
this this question but I mean I know in
my own town they needed a new bailer so
they could bail their aluminum cans you
know some people and that way if they
could bail more they could hold more and
then they could save on shipping because
they weren't shipping it all at the same
time I mean for a compost program it C
could cost $500 to get it going I mean
it kind of depends on what the grant
requests are that come in so it's I mean
I I wouldn't see this as a program where
somebody was going to come come in and
ask for
$250,000 at least that's not my
conception of it my conception of it is
to help small businesses grow and to
help
municipalities a follow-up question
please so in the town in your to
you said they went out and bought the
bins and what was the approximate cost
no idea I mean it wasn't a lot it wasn't
a lot um but you
know they they took a poll in the town
people were super excited to do uh
composting the selectman looked at it
they put some seed money into it we have
a contract and you know as I said we've
already diverted 32 tons of tra crash in
a year which is kind of
amazing well thank you thank you for the
answer representative Maguire thank you
Mr chairman thank you uh what fraction
of the tonnage is from New
Hampshire um I thought that I had
mentioned that number so I didn't do the
exact calculation but we've got 1.9 to I
mean we've got we got the LBA here maybe
she can do the number um no I'm kidding
it's uh we we have uh
1.92 3 million total we've got
1.1 in state and we have 8
820,000 out of state but that was 2022
that's the best I can do for you
thank there's no further question thank
you very much your testimony everybody
note that we have a written copy passed
out
next we'll call on uh Brody Dees from
the
nhma Welcome to the finance committee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the committee for taking my testimony
today um uh my name is berie desay for
the record I recog I I um represent the
New Hampshire Municipal Association I'm
here today to talk trash with all of you
sorry I had to in yeah I know sorry guys
um so the goal of this bill is to help
um municipalities fund
um the support and the initiatives for
local programs that will Pro that will
promote sustainable efficient and
affordable um food and other organic
waste disposal um the ultimate goal will
be limiting the amount of tonnage of
waste disposal that goes through whether
it's private or public landfills
ultimately um these landfills are funded
through tipping fees or other fee
schedules and any you know if you're in
municip it any difference in what they
can't fund through their fee schedules
will ultimately be funded by the
property taxpayer so in many ways we
view this as priming the pump not just
for initial property tax relief for
small programs that will uh create
better waste disposal practices more
sustainable waste disposal practices But
ultimately help local um governments
create better practices that will create
cost savings longterm down the road so
it's kind of thinking you know a uh an
ounce of cure today will save a uh a
pound of cure tomorrow um or I should
say an ounce of prevention today
prevents a pound of cure tomorrow um
there are municipalities are interested
in using these funds as the
representative mentioned you know it's
taking some time to hire someone to
administer to the grant program which we
understand in this labor market that can
be difficult but the interest is
certainly there New London is one
example but there are other
municipalities um and we can do a poll
of our membership to get more specifics
but we know there are other
municipalities that have you know not
just express interest to us but I assume
also express interest to some of you on
the finance committee um about this
program so um with that I'll take any
questions um I only know so much about
the waste disposal practices in our
state so I'm willing to to try to answer
anything here and if there's anything I
can't but the committee needs the
information I'll do some research on the
back end and get back to you guys thank
you questions from committee
members seeing none thank you very much
we'll next call on Reagan banet and he
has passed out a a written she has
passed out a written U sheet of her
testimony so you can follow it along
welcome thank you thank you thank you Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is Reagan biset I'm the executive
director of the Northeast resource
recovery Association we are a nonprofit
whose membership includes 90% of the
communities here in New Hampshire so
most to the communities represented uh
in this room and we help communities
with recycling composting and waste
reduction uh one of the things we do is
we actually help communities when they
have recycling that uh is ready to get
sent to a company to be recycled we
actually help make that connection um we
also provide a lot of education and
technical assistance to municipalities
to support their programs and so one of
the things we do is work with
communities on composting and food race
reduction and I can share that at our
annual conference that we hold each year
that brings about 300 people together
mostly from New Hampshire
municipalities last year at our postc
conference survey the number one topic
that communities wanted to learn more
about at this year's conference was food
waste and composting and that was a bit
of a surprise to us but I can say that
anecdotally we hear quite a bit from
communities that they're interested in
ways that they can reduce their food
waste and reduce the food waste that
we're sending to landfills so as you
heard from representative eel uh when we
look at the waste that we are disposing
of in New Hampshire we know from
National numbers that approximately 24%
of that waste coming from municipalities
and businesses is actually food waste so
it's a very significant component of the
trash that we're disposing of and in the
Northeast our municipalities are paying
more for disposal of trash compared to
many other regions in the country in the
continental US so it's it's a rather
expensive uh cost for our communities to
dispose of their trash so opportunities
to divert food waste provides the
potential to reduce costs for our
municipalities um specifically I wanted
to highlight that uh the city of Lebanon
they started a pilot program to help
their residents take their food waste
and have it composted on site uh a few
years ago and what they found is that
during that pilot program the city had
uh about a 30%
savings uh from composting that material
on site instead of disposing of it in
the landfill that the city
operates now our organization put
together a map for the entire State of
New Hampshire showing all of the
municipalities that we're aware of that
currently offer opportunities to
Residents to compost or otherwise manage
their food waste aside from disposal and
we also have on that map all the
businesses private businesses and Farms
that we're aware of that provide those
services and right now in terms of the
communities that are participating it's
about less than two dozen and in terms
of the businesses we're aware of that
provide services in New Hampshire for
communities to compost or otherwise
manage their food waste it's under two
dozen so there's maybe eight farms uh
maybe 10 businesses so really there's a
real opportunity to uh increase business
opportunities for Farms or other private
businesses that would like to help
communities reduce their food waste and
manage their food waste in a different
way um because when you look at that map
there's a lot of big holes right now so
you know our organization doesn't take a
position on bills as a matter of policy
but I hope that this testimony is
helpful to you all as you consider uh
how this bill uh might impact our
communities here in New Hampshire so I'm
happy to answer any questions you might
have questions from the
committee representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you Miss
biset for taking the question I I um be
because we're A legislature we we end up
uh continuously looking at State driven
Solutions and I'm just curious in your
experience or general awareness has
another approach an alternative been
tried anywhere where uh an effective
public relations um effort is put
together to share with the public the
facts around waste to encourage uh at
home
composting has there been efforts to get
individuals involved in solving this
problem instead of just going to a a
collective
solution certainly yes I mean both with
managing food waste in recycling um
individual public education is always an
important component of trying to spread
that
message I think what's challenging is at
the same time expecting individuals to
um each be managing their own food waste
in this instance um you know it's asking
a lot of people and so it is easier and
more convenient for residents if their
municipality or say a local business is
able to offer services for them you know
not everyone wants to compost in their
backyard um I used to compost in my own
backyard and eventually I was quite lazy
about it and uh didn't turn the pile
enough and eventually you know some
unpleasant odors came out and I found
that it was easier for me to work with a
local business that would haul away my
food scraps um but I think it's a lot to
expect individuals to go out and seek
out those resources on their own and so
one of the benefits of knowing if your
community has that opportunity for you
and you know your residents are
participating it just makes it easy
but yes absolutely education is always
an important component and you know can
only have so much
success further from the committee nink
thank you Mr chairman thank you Miss Des
I have a it's not on the topic of waste
food but it is on the general topic of U
Solid Waste Management uh can you tell
us I mean My Town recently uh decided
not to recycle Plastics M and can you
tell us what percentage of plastics
actually get
recycled yes thank you for the question
I'm happy to answer that so there's a
lot of confusion around Plastics
understandably um again public education
can only go so far and there is some
misinformation sometimes so one thing
I'd like to start by saying is that if
you're if you are recycling Plastics or
any other material that your your town
or say your business business says can
be put in your recycling bin you can
have a very high confidence that that's
being recycled now you might have heard
a number thrown around that only six or
seven or 8% of all Plastics are recycled
what that refers to is all the plastic
that's ever been produced so that
includes the plastic in this microphone
that includes the plastic on the
dashboard of your car that's all
Plastics what that doesn't mean is that
only N9 or six or 7% of the plastic that
you put in your recycling bin is is
recycled so um I always let people know
recycle what your community says can be
accepted and you can be very confident
that that is being
recycled
did thank
you further from the
committee seeing none we'll next call on
director whimet from thank you the uh
the Hampshire Department of
Environmental security
Services what I say Services security
have thank you for the correction thank
you Mr chair we like to think we provide
some security as
well uh good afternoon for the record my
name is Mike whimet I service director
of the waste management division for New
Hampshire Dees I'm joined today by
Michael Nor who heads up our materials
management education and planning
section and is uh very much engaged on
our work to advance food waste diversion
um the the agency is not taking a
position on this bill but we do want to
make ourselves available to committee
for any questions you might have and I'd
just like to make a few remarks uh
keying off on some of the things that
have been said already um indeed we're
working in Earnest on uh uh working on
ruem to establish a grant program for
the solid waste management fund we
anticipate great interest in that grant
program um on the on the part of
municipalities because really
municipalities for most people are kind
of where it's at with respect to their
household Waste Management they either
have a municipality that arranges for
curbside pickup and disposal of their
waste or they have a municipality that
operates a transfer station where they
go every week to take their trash and
recyclables so we expect them to be a
key uh recipients of some of the grants
that we would expect to make we also
anticipate that um private entities and
farmers and others who have already
established compost programs who or who
wish to start them um will come to this
Grand program to try to would either if
they already have a Compost Facility
they would try to you know make some
Capital Investments to advance the
amount of capacity that they have to to
treat compost um and also uh new
startups that want to start and and we
really I mean the whole purpose of the
food wasteband for the large generators
of food waste was to try to incentivize
um the development of a network of
facilities um of different types and
different technologies that could manage
food waste we also anticipate that one
or more anerobic digestor outfits might
come in looking for some matching money
to advance that technology and and
provide that service to particularly for
that's an actually a very good
technology can work really well for
single stream types sort of a very
reliable kind of food waste which might
become from a manufacturer or from a
grocery store or something like that and
then um we also anticipate that some of
the uh entities that are subject to the
food waste band these are the folks who
generate more than a ton per week of
food waste um may come to us saying we
could use some assistance in developing
or or capitalizing certain you know
infrastructure for managing go trans
transitioning from disposing of our food
waste in the dumpster to collecting it
in some fashion and then transporting it
to a facility that can uh that can
divert it from disposal so um with that
there was also some talk about education
and we certainly um you know we we've
been working very hard to advance our
website and the amount of Outreach that
we do we work very closely with a solid
waste working group as the chair as the
sponsor has indicated um to uh look at
uh really advancing our education and
Outreach I would note that you know um
the the hard part about using solely
education or Outreach to try to advance
a new way to manage waste is that it's
really hard to get more convenient then
everything you generate you just throw
in the trash and somebody picks it up
and makes it go away that's really hard
to compete with so um that's one of the
reasons the food wasteband was
implemented because it is really hard to
convince people that it's you know
there's anything easier than just
throwing it away and because they don't
see necessarily the impacts of that or
even necessarily directly the the cost
impacts um there sometimes need to be
some kind of incentivization the solid
waste management fund the food waste
band provides sort of incentivization to
say okay if you're a big generator and
you've got access to a facility near you
that can handle this in a way that isn't
landfill disposal then we're going to
expect you to Avail yourself of that
kind of service um that's one way to
incentivize it but the other way is to
provide these matching grants to help
defay the costs of the initial Capital
cost of developing these facilities and
that's what we envision the grants that
will be making um under this program to
to really help help to to accomplish and
with that I I open it to
questions representative Maguire thank
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Winson um we heard that the fund
currently has $900,000 is that correct
and when do you expect to make the first
grant that's right we we're working in
Earnest on rule making we we we don't do
much without rule making first and so
we're working on rule making we expect
that to happen over the next several
months and certainly conservatively
speaking we would expect that by
calendar year end we'd be in a position
to start a iing and soliciting Grant
applications to administer the grant
program representative
priest thank you Mr chairman for take
and thank you for taking my question um
you mentioned that there was a food
waste ban in the state that's correct
that just became effective this month
actually and uh essentially for
generators of food waste who generate
more than one ton per week of food waste
uh if they have access to a facility
within 25 miles of their facility that
can process that food waste and accept
it in a manner other than landfill
disposal then they're banned from from
disposing of that food waste in a
landfill now has to be said this is a
brand new program we're really working
on education and Outreach we're not out
there we don't have cops out there
looking to bust somebody because they
disposed of their food waste we're
working right now on doing a food waste
study to understand understand that
Universe better and then we'll spend a
lot of time trying to get out and
educating those folks on how they can
comply with the ban okay fur as a
follow-up question um does the
Department of Environmental Services
have kind of an overreach goal of how
much waste they're wanting to divert by
what year and and how are we getting
closer to that goal sure great great
question we we do we have a legislative
directive actually that there's a a goal
was established by the legislature to
reduce the amount of waste that is
disposed of in landfills or incinerators
um by 25% by the year 2030 and then by
45% by the year 2050 that's what's in
the statute right now and um we're
working towards that the I have to say
the solid waste working group which is
chaired by this build sponsor has been
you know have meeting monthly really now
for a couple of years to really try to
advance the kind of policy and programs
that will help us achieve that uh ways
that we we do hope to do that the food
waste band is actually a great one
because it just so happens that uh at
least probably around 25% of the weight
of of the tonnage of of waste that is
disposed of in a landfill is is is
identified as likely being organic or
food waste so if we can make significant
progress on that piece that gets us a
long way to that goal
goal I'm okay one more question um and
again what I've been hearing is that
with this food waste
recycling uh that's being proposed um
and the food waste
band 25% of
the of the total tonnage could be
diverted and could be reused is that
correct uh I think you know I don't
think that the food waste B alone going
to achieve that we we've got other U you
know work that we're doing we're trying
to advance even simple recycling um in
terms of uh you know the the solid waste
management fund is not just for food
waste grants it's for Grants to do for
anybody that's going to advance a
technology or a facility or provide um
something that's going to move the
needle on reducing the amount of overall
waste that we dispose of so as the chair
as as the sponsor of the bill mentioned
if uh if someone comes in and wants a
small grant to get a baor because it'll
increase the amount of a certain type of
plastic or aluminum that they can
recycle that's a great fit and then we
can make a grant for that they can get
that and uh you know anything on the way
on up to an anerobic digestion facility
that's going to have you know a
significant in investment of capital
that wants some assistance to to uh to
to try to set up something like that for
food waste so it it really runs the
gamut of the waste types and we're going
to be trying to attack it on all fronts
thank you representative Edwards for a
question uh uh thank you uh Mr shair I I
I I heard in your testimony that um uh
education alone won't move the needle
much at least that's my interpretation
and part of your testimony as as
somebody who consumes a lot of media I
don't believe I have ever seen a public
relations piece uh encouraging uh
families to take care of their own food
waste issues and
so so I guess I have a a two-part
question in here is you know uh are you
aware of any communities anywhere in the
country that have tried to get the
public more directly involved in
self-sufficiency uh and and uh if if if
you thought about it how much would it
cost for us to do a test pilot on um a a
public relations campaign in lie of uh
grants to build more government
infrastructure that that's a great
question and I please don't take my
remarks to suggest that education isn't
important to us at the department it
very much is and we spend a lot of time
and effort uh advancing that I think
it's it's it's both and really in this
case um as far as um there certainly
have we our ability in the department um
to spend a lot of time in resources on
Outreach has been somewhat limited
because for many years our program was
very resource deficient
and um we have only recently um in the
last few years gotten a hand a couple of
staff that can work full-time on this
and they have done some great things we
have a website that's really helpful now
that can help instruct people on what
they can do with any type any any any
number of types of ways for recycling
and what have you I'm certainly I I
don't have any specific examples but I'm
sure that there are other states that
have done exactly what you said where
they where they have um Outreach to help
people encourage people to home compost
a longtime home composter I live in a
setting where it it makes sense to do
that if I lived here in town my
neighbors might not appreciate it very
much but where I live I can do it and it
works great and that as a first instance
it I I compost my own food scraps and it
advances my own garden so it works great
for me but for many people um who who
either aren't interested in that or or
don't have the setting for it um
disposing of food waste um in a way that
gets it to a facility where it can be
composted even though it's not in their
backyard is still a worthy a worthy
goal represent
lean thank you Mr chairman and nice to
see you Mike a question on Sear charges
would the department support assessing a
search charge per ton of
waste I'm not in a position to say what
our position would be at this point um I
can tell you that that is something we
have explored over over time over
several years and as you know it takes
takes a certain set of circumstances
where there's support for that both at
the legislative level and the governor's
level um and but certainly it's
something we're willing to work with the
committee on it it's it's easy math
right representative e is absolutely
correct it's about 2 million tons of
waste that are disposed of uh in
landfills or in our one waste energy
facility each year and so every dollar
of a SE charge would likely raise $2
million so that you know those kinds of
revenues could really uh pay for what
currently is a general funded program
our our you know for argument sake let's
say a $2 tipping fee a s charge that
could provide $4 million which would
essentially cover all the operating
costs of our Solid Waste program and
leave ample funds to make annual grants
for advancing waste reduction thank you
thank you Mr chairman represent
Daniels thank you Mr chairman how many
pro processing facilities exist in
Hampshire uh you mean processing for
food waste yes I don't sure I know the
answer Mike Mike might more likely know
the answer so we we currently have 10
operating permitted composting
facilities in the state those are the
the facilities that are permitted to
accept food waste for composting okay
thank you uh followup followup
um with the
budgets I from what I've seen throughout
the state really tight this year uh what
makes you think the priorities are going
to be given to Solid Waste uh reduction
as opposed to uh increasing Road the the
quality of the roads and plowing and uh
other things that towns and
municipalities need to take care of I
don't honestly know where the priorities
will be um you know our job here in the
waste division is to um Implement our
programs to the best of our ability it's
up to the legislature to decide where
the funding priorities will
go one final final so I guess the the
root of my question is if we took this
million
dollars what are the chances that people
are going to be going after the
grants oh I think that as opposed to the
other priorities that they need to take
take care of because it is a 50/50 Grant
sure we have very close working
relationship with our municipalities
I'll take them as an example because I
think they would be kind of our first
inline customers for these grants
um they work very hard they they're very
aware of the costs that are associated
with their management of waste and I you
know I wouldn't expect them to
necessarily frivolously want to go
Advance a program that on balance was
going to cost them more money than than
it than it saved them but for the
reasons I think you heard from the other
Witnesses um a small investment such as
a Bor for example um Can often pay for
itself quite quickly um because of the
increase revenues from collecting
recyclables um
uh advancing making small investment in
a composting program at the municipal
level could save uh you know essentially
you know representative eil talked about
the $60 to $80 a ton uh rate that uh you
know was reported to exist in New
Hampshire I actually think those numbers
might be a little dated I'm hearing
higher numbers now and the new contracts
that are being executed between
municipalities and waste haulers are
much closer to the $100 a ton level um
so when you think about it that that way
if a municip even a small municipality
can avoid 10 tons of uh of uh of food
waste going into their dumpster and
hauled off to the landfill that's $1,000
savings right there so um I think that
there will be great interest in that
even in and maybe even because we having
tight fiscal
times representative R thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr whsa it's nice to
see you again um aside from the savings
on
property taxes that people spend you
know when to operate a transfer station
or a landfill in their town and um and
also the fact that diverting
waste provides a longer lifespan for
that landfill are there any other
benefits to keeping food waste out of a
landfill there are um you know one of
the the managing a landfill is a complex
activity and one of the things that
makes it complex is that landfills
generate landfill gas which is primar
methane and um the reason that they
generate gas is because when you put
waste in a landfill the organic material
like food waste and organic waste um
eventually you know consume all the
oxygen in their degradation they create
an anerobic environment and then at that
point all the degradation that happens
converts that food waste or or other
organic waste to methane and so that
methane then needs to be collected uh
and we work really hard to make sure our
landfills have systems for collecting
and flaring or burning that gas for
energy recovery in some cases but the
reality is is that even the best run
landfill is going to have some
significant fugitive emissions of
methane and methane is a is a greenhouse
gas it's a it contributes to climate
change so it's uh anything we can do to
reduce the amount of organic loading in
our landfills will tend to reduce the
significantly the amount of methane
that's generated by those landfills can
I can I add on to that that also an
issue of concern to the legislature of
late has been leech a and organic waste
in in landfills contributes to leech a
because it contains moisture and as that
organic waste breaks down it releases
that moisture which then filters out as
leachate so it's another way to uh look
at the benefits of of removing food
waste from
landfills home home composting isn't too
bad I've been doing it for 50 years you
do need a shredder and I've had the same
Shredder for 30 years and I break up a
big pile of leaves covered over it with
a with a tarp two three times a week I
take my bucket of garbage and throw in a
start up the machine throw in a armful
of leaves throw in the garbage behind it
I separate the meat and the and the uh
bone scraps and they disappear from the
raccoons and the and the fox and the
crows and the only problem it's been
lately is the uh turkeys come and tear
the tear it apart looking for worms and
spread it out more than I'd like but
I've always had a good amount of
fertilizer and been doing it for 50
years anything
else represent McGuire thank you Mr
chairman do you know what the Tipping
fees and search charges if any are in
the state of
Maine um I can't say I know the specific
numbers but that question is difficult
even in New Hampshire it's hard for me
to say because everybody who has a
contract with a waste huler disposer has
their price and it's based on it's
Market based it's based on the amount
it's based on a whole bunch of things so
it's hard to say my my understanding is
that those rates are probably in line
with what we're seeing in New
Hampshire if if the question was about
sear charges that are paid on top of
tipping fees we can get you that
information we have that information for
the state of main I just don't have it
on hand thank you if you give it to the
LBA they'll be able to distribute it to
okay and and presumably that would give
you tonnage and other
information because you would know x per
ton plus total you know thank you all
right we've got another bill we got to
move on to um the plan is that 619 will
go to division one and they will
be and they will be uh working on it for
exing I plan an exec session on the
bills that have been uh
done through division one for next what
did I say Tuesday at 1 10 Tuesday at 10
Tuesday at 10 o'clock next Tuesday at 10
o'clock we'll have an exact session on
probably four or five bills yeah I think
it'll take two minutes because they're
all retained right so well we need to be
here anyway all right we'll close the
hearing on House Bill 619 as I say it's
going to division one for further I have
a a blue sheet with only signed by Brody
Dees but I also have um the house remote
testified bill has 49 people in support
three opposed one neutral so those will
go in the record as well uh it seems to
be a well supported Bill and we'll get
ready now for next to uh House Bill 519
from division
three Amendment as
yes I can I go to Ed thank
you take a quick break all right we'll
call upon representative
Edwards thank
you uh thank you Mr chair I um uh I'm
I'm representive Jess Edwards District
31 Auburn Chester candy and Deerfield
and uh I want to talk today about a uh a
non- gerine amendment to HB 519 the
Senate uh the speaker uh approved this
as a non- gerine Amendment um for some
some
background uh the this committee uh
heard HB 519 referred it to division 3
division 3 uh had testimony on the
28th um uh that this bill is a a good
bill it recognizes Waypoint as a vital
service provider for homeless services
for uh 18 to 24 year olds it's kind of a
unique service in the state something
that the governor wanted but didn't get
it into the budget uh DHHS wanted it but
didn't get in in the budget so uh
representative walner and others uh did
uh it's like I said it's a good bill on
the 28th of of um January um uh at the
50 minute and 50c Mark I made a
commitment to uh the people who run
Waypoint that the language of
519 was going to be protected we were
going to move the language of
519 into the budget but I did not commit
to a dollar amount I just said you know
we don't know how much money we're going
to have but I'm not going to lose your
language that that's on the record uh in
uh in U on the from the 28th so what I'm
proposing to do today is to take
59 um and take this uh non- gerain
Amendment uh and have this non jurain
Amendment tweaked a little bit so that
it becomes a replace all it it's it's
not quite a replace all right now this
amendment uh would become an additional
section and and so I'm I'm I'm I'm
recommending we replace all uh with a
new section and this new section is to
amend current statute which is RSA
151 by adding a section that says that
the violation of the patient Bill of
Rights the Department of Health and
Human Services shall not contract with
any Hospital found in violation of any
section of RSA 151 colon 21 the patients
Bill of Rights so in a way this is not
new policy the patient Bill of Rights
has been debated and it is in statute um
the issue gets to be one of uh helping
to encourage uh our hospitals to comply
with the patient Bill of Rights there's
been a rather spectacular case
uh that's been that we've been made
aware of and um so we we've had
Advocates come and ask that we do a
little bit more to take the existing
policy of the state and try to do what
we can to encourage the hospitals to
cooperate with um our legislative intent
to have the patient Bill of Rights uh
respected so so that's what this non-
gerain amendment would do again I I
propose a tweak to it to make it a
replace all use 519 as the carrier have
us execut next week if if we like it
enough to send it to the house I'd like
to have the house take a position on it
that's why uh I I I want to get it to
the house floor so that it's not some
Finance um in in the
darkness sticking it in it's a it's a
position of the house if we do it that
way I'll take any
questions representative tki thank you
Mr chairman thank you representative for
taking my question um can you please
share how many hospitals actually
contract with the
state any that do in the future would be
subjected to this law so regardless of
what the number is today this is a
future oriented Bill and any future
contracts with any Hospital would need
to comply I think we have on the order
of um of Mr Bradley is here I I think we
have on the order of about 23 hospitals
of varying sizes throughout the state
but he can he can provide a better
number than that PA I think anytime
there's a Medicare Medicare patient and
half the money is coming from the state
so virtually anybody that has Medicare
patients is is billing with the state
I was just trying to determine how many
uh what it would en Encompass in terms
of the the scope of this so may I just
have a a followup follow thank you I
appreciate it um I know that the the
case that you just alluded to and didn't
go into detail about um but is there um
any record of how many violations of the
patient Bill of Rights has occurred or
is this just um an attempt at that one
um situation that happened very recently
what was exposed was an anecdotal
example of a grotesque failure to
respect the Bill of Rights where
potentially life-saving uh Health Care
intervention was being denied because
the person refused the covid shot it was
it wasn't just an incident it was an
extremely serious and bizarre incident
in my view and and it's clearly a
violation of the Bill of Rights where
it's says vaccine status should not be
affected now anecdotally i' I've heard
that there are other cases that are
having similar problems because uh the
the
offending
hospital changed their policy enough to
let non-id people get services but any
other other vaccines that they thought
were necessary or mandatory uh was still
the cost for denial of U of care and um
I I haven't had an opportunity to
corroborate those anecdotal examples
beyond the the one that made the news
that required our speaker to get
personally involved and the AG to get
personally involved but uh but what this
would do is just make it really clear to
everyone involved that the legislature
and the governor uh approved approved
the patient Bill of Rights and we did it
because we wanted it to be followed and
this isn't a new requirement it's an
existing requirement just please comply
with a patient Bill of Rights in in
terms of scope I it explicitly limited
it to the hospitals and not every health
care provider I did that because I
appreciate that there is a regulatory
burden involved here and I and I wanted
to do a light touch on the regulatory
burden and so by establishing a beach
head with the hospitals I hope that it
sets an example for other health
providers to just voluntarily comply
with New Hampshire law thank can I have
one last final thank you I appreciate
you um pointing that out which was sort
of related to my first question on on
the language of just hospitals um I am
concerned however on the underlying bill
you and I spoke briefly about it before
this hearing um the amendment as drafted
that as you said does keep the original
language in there um I am concerned
about the um the Waypoint situation and
keeping that forward facing to the
public um and now you're saying you want
to do a complete um redraft to remove
that section um don't you think that
this might be a better vehicle uh to go
as amendment to House belill 2 why do we
need to um put the Waypoint bill in
Jeopardy well you got a couple different
issues there and they're both perfectly
valid in my view one you and I share the
U emphasis on doing something to help
Waypoint there's no air between us in
terms of making sure that we consider
the language that's in 519 and to
migrate it into House Bill 2 I've
already been instructed um the division
3 LBA to make sure that that happens and
it's one of the things I'm going to
follow up on um if if if we followed
typical mechanics we would be retaining
519 in any case if we were to retain it
it loses its public visibility so there
isn't really an advantage to keeping it
in 519 if we're going to retain 519
anyways because it loses its public
awareness until the beginning of next
term so so I think by the beginning of
next term we'll have put this into hb2
will have discussed it we'll have fought
very hard to try to find some money for
it because it's 500,000 a year and new
money so it's a big ask but I want us to
look for it so so we share the concern
about protecting a uh Waypoint in terms
of visibility and and and concern by the
legislature the reason I want to have
this non- gerine amendment go to the
house floor is because um I think well
one I'm guessing but I think it'll pass
the house and when it passes the house
then we will have a very clear statement
to reinforce the existing public law
that the patient Bill of Rights is
important to us and then therefore it
should be important to our health care
providers thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr chairman repres
Stringham for Mr Edwards um the patient
Bill rights representative Edwards I
worked hard for that title thank you uh
thank you for uh introducing this
amendment the patient Bill of Rights is
already law and included as you said as
RSA 151
218 um I think you would agree that
hospitals are one of the most heavily
regulated businesses in the country they
have to comply with countless
regulations dealing with Public Safety
worker safety Finance requirements hi
Hippa Patient Bill rights many many
other things with the unev unenviable
task of establishing guidelines that
take into com uh often take into account
competing priorities of for example
protecting worker safety and patient
safety uh I I've certainly been to
Dartmouth hospital I've seen Patient
Bill of Rights posted in the elevator
before it sounds like one thing happened
to one patient that there was a
disagreement which is going to happen
happen uh which you described as serious
but can you explain why we really should
amend a bill that we all support um with
with uh this issue here um that is
already covered in RSA uh 151 21 which I
know our hospitals all take seriously uh
with a non- gerain uh U and by implying
that we're going to threaten Dartmouth
hospital with or one hospital by taking
Contracting is voluntary there's no
threat it's just saying if you want to
do business with the state you'll comply
with state law that's not a threat is it
representative did you mean to say that
well the I I what I think what I think
this implies is I mean they are under
contract they're already agreed to uh
apply with a patient Bill of Rights and
all other laws would you agree with that
no and I apologize for interrupting you
no we're not here to debate uh and so
the the Takeaway on to me on your
question is um you know I agree
hospitals are heavily regulated and have
a huge compliance function uh as you
pointed out they're already aware of the
patient Bill of Rights if they're
posting it in the elevator so so we're
we're not really expecting them to do
anything that they're not doing but I
would just point out that this in this
particular instance this Hospital put a
tremendous amount of Senior Management
effort into denying a patient their
rights under the patient Bill of Rights
and so I'm not asking them to do
anything but what you're suggesting is
to take the patient Bill a right
seriously so I think we're actually in
agreement on
that thank you very much all
right further questions from committee
representative R thank thank you Mr
chair um I have a couple questions um
representative thank you for taking my
question um why did you select this bill
specifically to attach a non-gain
amendment to great question and because
uh like Willie Sutton said I rob banks
because that's where the money is th
this bill was the only Bill in division
3 that I had any control over so when
you only have one option you exercise
that option
so so that's that's why 519 got picked
and because in division 3 it was
universally accepted that we want to
take 519 language and put it into hb2 we
already had decided that the the utility
of
hb19 given that the alternative was to
retain it it had near zero utility as a
retained bill so I'm giving it a reason
a purpose a repurpose for life
okay follow up um but what value is
there in 519 with just a language um
isn't its value in the
appropriation uh we would have to debate
the
money we're going to have to debate the
money and the and the division three
deliberations around the budget in any
case nothing is different this you know
taking 519 as a shell and and putting
the non- gerain amendment and it doesn't
change any of the work we're already
committed to doing we're going to take
the the the language put it into hb2
we're going to go through our our our
budget cycle where we look at all the
Departments we're going to look the fact
that they're going to ask us for more
money than we have and we're going to
try to find money for Waypoint all of
that's going to happen 519 is irrelevant
at this this point okay and then just
one more um in in the language in your
Amendment representative you mentioned
that um Department of Health and Human
Services shall not contract with any
Hospital found in violation does that
apply to every single contract that a
hospital may have with the state I I
don't I don't I'm not up on every
boilerplate uh piece of language there
is on our DHHS contracts but if you're
familiar with Contracting there's
typically you know a statement of work
that comes in and so sort of the section
c of it where it's Unique to that
contract and then there are an endless
Gob of pages of boilerplate and I don't
know what it goes into the boiler plate
but I think once um DHHS adopted this
language and stuck it in the boiler
plate there'd be no additional
administrative overhead to doing it or
maintaining it was that your question um
I don't think it was no not really I I
it was what I wanted to say though
yeah um no I no I I really wanted to get
to the fact that you know we're putting
every single contract at stake with
hospitals and we don't even know what
the extent of those are and I I guess
I'm I'm asking what is the total amount
of risk in losing services to the state
that we currently contract with
hospitals I mean if there was instead of
let's say going to a hospital and say
you violated the the patient Bill of
Rights you need to reverse the decision
um that would be the most
straightforward easiest least expensive
solution to a
problem but I'm I'm wondering have you
done any assessment as to what the
exposure is in losing those Hospital
Services if a hospital is found to be
invit I don't think we're going to lose
Services I it's already state law that
we have a patient Bill of Rights the
expectation is already that the hospital
should comply there should there should
be no threat of a discontinuity and and
a service relationship because it's
already in the law you know so so what
has been was lacking was the an an
efficient enforcement capability that
caused um there to be sort of this
public effort to get some media
attention on it to to pull in the
speaker of the house to pull in the
governor to pull in the AG you know all
this extra arrial you know work to to to
get a simple voluntary compliance thing
voluntarily complied with so so I I I I
do think there's a need for the bill
because I think it's valuable for us to
to
reate uh to the hospitals not to every
health care provider but just to The
Limited hospitals um that we were
serious when we passed the patient Bill
of Rights we weren't just kidding around
we really expected before we prolong any
there are people from the hospital that
are going to come up and people from the
hospital Association and people from
Dartmouth hospital so yeah and by the
way we'll talk about it again when we
EXA yeah so we don't need to beat this
to death so so Mr Speaker what I'll
commit to is if it doesn't come up the
answer doesn't come up the
representative asks a good question of
about how many contracts with how many
uh hospitals might be affected by
including this in the boilerplate we'll
hope to find it that out from the
hospital Association so well or DHHS I
just ask Mr White you know to tell me
yeah further forther
witness seeing none did you have any
representative
muray yes I did thank you Mr chair if I
can just take a few seconds um can you
address enforcement though because I'm
hearing about if there's a violation and
I'm just curious if there's a violation
do all these contracts disappear or do
we say well you'll have well we'll make
they'll be gone they'll be good until
the next year and then you're not going
to get them what if there's a violation
and the violation is corrected I'm a
little concerned about enforcement and
is there a bill bat that's going to say
oh violation contracts are null and
voids we keep in mind that the hope and
the intent is just to stimulate the
voluntary compliance that we expected
when we put this in the patient Bill of
Rights into law to begin with and what
the bill says is that DHHS shall not
contract with any hospital it doesn't
have further language to say We'll void
any contract that becomes uh knowing it
it it it's it's a future oriented
looking thing and my hope my intent is
that um uh there will never be any more
enforcement than just uh putting in
there this is part of our contract
please
comply further yeah just thank you I
think you sort of made my point and that
since there is no enforcement we have no
idea what the Fallout of this bill would
be if there is a violation so thank
you I think I I think I answered that
we're expecting voluntary compliance and
that as part of a Contracting process
DHHS would have a language that the that
the hospital would voluntarily sign off
on obligating them to comply with state
law it's not that's not very
uh that's not a big reach to ask him to
voluntarily comply with state
law all right seeing nothing further
we'll see if Melissa BLC is she in the
room yes she
is
welcome thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm Melissa blasic I'm
here representing rebuild NH I just
wanted to give a little background to
the story um I was contacted the day
after Christmas
by Miss Shannon
Buttermore and um sorry I'm very short
okay um and she was being denied a
kidney transplant by Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center for not receiving the
covid-19 vaccine now she had already
complied with their other vaccine
requirements which was to get the hepb
series and the yearly influenza vaccine
but she did not want to get the covid-19
vaccine
um we notified lobbyists for Dartmouth
Hitchcock and um the hospital
Association about this and really kind
of got nowhere um I was one of the
co-sponsors of this bill that added this
section to the patient Bill of Rights in
2022 it passed unanimously through both
Chambers um so 425 people were very
clear what they were intending which was
that no patient be denied any medical
treatment for not getting any vaccine it
was not specific to the covid vaccine so
yes it took an entire PR
campaign uh to get any type of
satisfaction for Miss
Buttermore um and she they did remove
their covid-19 requirement for kidney
transplants and so she can move forward
and get the treatment that she needs
however this is not some isolated
incident this is their
policy and the other I still have not
gotten satisfaction of seeing a policy
out of Dartmouth Hitchcock that says
that they've removed all of their
vaccine requirements and there are a lot
of patients who are still being denied
transplants for not getting other
vaccines now miss Buttermore was a rare
breed not many people are Fighters and
that's just a reality most people are
not willing willing to file a lawsuit
like she was most people are not willing
to go public and have an entire PR
campaign like she was most of these
people are sick and they will just go to
another state and get the transplant
that they need from another hospital and
move on with their lives and I don't
blame them okay but that doesn't change
the fact that the hospital has a WID
spread policy and that they have denied
many people this care so the question
kept being asked how many contracts how
many hospitals will this affect well I
my hope is zero because my hope is that
every single hospital is following the
patient Bill of Rights but when you have
to fight so hard for your rights by
going through an entire PR campaign
lawyering up finding people to pay for
that lawsuit do those rights really
exist and the re reality was that we
really did not get a lot of satisfaction
until we got the elected politicians on
board because there just wasn't
enforcement enough from in my opinion um
law enforcement and so you know just
last week the executive Council tabled a
Dartmouth contract because they still
have not gotten full satisfaction that
they are in full compliance with the law
and so I think what this amendment could
do is once again provide a little bit
more enforcement through the legislative
body um that ultimately truly was what
got satisfaction for Miss
Buttermore um unfortunately it was not
law enforcement so um I want to thank
representative Edwards for pursuing this
and um I'll take any
questions questions miss
blazik seeing none thank you for your
testimony and your
Championship okay now we get a chance
for Dartmouth to respond Matthew hood is
here from Dartmouth
Health thank you for
coming thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Matthew Hood vice president of
government relations at Dartmouth
Health uh and I'm here obviously to uh
speak to the questions and some of the
concerns that the amendment raises from
our perspective
um one of them you've heard a fair
amount already talk about enforcement
and nothing in the amendment would
change the current enforcement mechanism
which is the sole jurisdiction is with
the Superior Court um and that's a real
reasonable topic for conversation about
who and what agency might be the best to
navigate this space for example the
patient Bill of Rights has a number of
different Provisions some pertain to
financial
matters uh and delegating that that
authority to help uh a patient navigate
financial matters to the institution
would that be the Attorney General's
Office of Consumer Protection for
example might be implicated in resolving
that type of issue um there are issues
sorry just going to look at my notes for
a
moment uh there there are requirements
in the patient Bill of Rights about lure
of level of the provider um
but presumably the oplc doesn't have a
role in enforcement of the Bill of
Rights there are also Provisions about
denial of care based on age sex sexual
orientation race Etc but I'm presuming
that the um commission for human rights
doesn't have a role in enforcement in
this uh I could go on insurance Network
plans Etc department of insurance
doesn't have a role so the question that
this that's been raised about
enforcement is is if someone feels that
the patient Bill of Rights has been
violated what are they going to do um
and under the bill under the patient
Bill of Rights even as it would be
amended they'd still have to go to the
Superior Court to prove a violation um
I'm not sure that that's what this body
is desirous of I think it's desirous of
quicker resolution of Patient Bill of
Rights
violations um so that's the first piece
the second piece that I'd like to raise
is the idea of individual versus
facility liability um so you could have
an
act I'll give a hypothetical situation
you have a new employee who's doing
intake one of the requirements I think
it's the first requirement of the
patient Bill of Rights is that patients
are given notice of their rights and
responsibilities uh under the patient
Bill of Rights and the processes for
navigating disputes they're under um
they have to be they have to be given
those and sign an acknowledgement that
they have been given those conceivably
you could see a situation where the
person administers all of the
information but neglects to take a
signature that's a violation of the
patient Bill of Rights presumably every
piece of the patient Bill of Rights is
in there for a reason and has import um
but that employee wouldn't be fired
presumably they would be there would be
like corrective action you'd say here
this is what we tried to do this is what
we're required to do Under the patient
Bill of
Rights but there's a there's not that
type of opportunity for remedy in the
situation under the under the current
posture of the patient Bill of Rights
when there's a violation by the facility
I get agency I get employee liability
for the acts employer liability for the
acts of the employee I just wanted to
point out that the one would hope that
there would be a different venue and
opportunity to correct alleged
violations of the patient Bill Bill of
Rights my final question for this
committee has to do with scope and
people have raised that a number of
times I can't excuse me I can't tell you
the number of contracts that Dartmouth
Health has with the state never mind all
of the facilities in the state I'm sure
we could find that out from the
Department of Health and services or
elsewise um however for me it pertains
to what is this what is the
applicability is it literally everything
and so if it's if it's contracts like
were in front of the executive Council
recently is it contracts to provide
Clinical Services at New Hampshire
hospital is it Medicaid contracts in
which case the the termination of those
contracts for a violation without an
opportunity to address that violation
would be the 30 the 36,000 Medicaid
patients that Dartmouth Health serves
would presumably have to go elsewhere
not get that service and
so um I'm not that that provides the
remedy that that the person who is
alleging a violation of the patient Bill
of Rights I'm not sure that that
provides the type of address that they
would be
seeking I'll stop there I suspect I'll
be I'm happy to answer questions so I'll
suspect that uh I'll have that
opportunity representative lean for a
question then representative
Naval thank you Mr chairman it's been a
long time since I've seen you when you
sat uh on the other side of the Street
here but thanks for taking my question I
guess I I'm a little concerned that your
testimonies seem to be more worried
about enforcement than following the
bill of patient rights I maybe I'm wrong
in that assumption but uh it seems like
the argument should be that the hospital
will do everything they can to follow
the patient Bill of Rights and I and I
appreciate the question slash um
reiteration having ad libed it I
neglected to include that in the very
part of very opening part of my uh
comments which would be we take very
seriously the patient Bill of Rights and
wanting to make sure that there are
violations of the patient Bill of Rights
I I I um so I apologize for not saying
that
upfront thank you thank you Mr
chairman further
questions thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking the question
does does uh Dartmouth Hitchcock have
Prima fashi any written policies that
are at directly at odds with the
patients Bill of
Rights so there has been um
communication between the the Attorney
General's office and the office of
general counsel at Dartmouth Health to
determine whether or not there are
policies in place that violate the
patient Bill of Rights um and I I feel
it's important to take this moment to
make a
distinction between
a policy that required covid vaccination
in order to have a procedure which has
been reversed that policy has been
reversed
acknowledged um and a violation of the
patient Bill of Rights which relevant
section provides that a patient can't be
denied Services solely on the solely on
the basis of vaccination status the
healthcare delivery is a fairly complex
communication between patient and
provider and there could be lots of
reasons why um vaccinations would be
encouraged now strongly encouraged but
not required but there could be other
pieces that would impact the decision to
proceed with a care course of treatment
or
not followup yeah a quick followup I I
think if I heard previous testimony uh
today uh indicated that uh uh they they
hadn't changed the PO the change it with
regard to co which I think you've made
pretty clear but hadn't changed it with
regard to uh other other vaccines is
that a correct was that a
correct i' I'd take issue with that
obser with that conclusion and I would
say that our office of General Council
has done a fairly comprehensive um
review with the clinical teams and other
people in the hospital to determine that
there not are no vac or no vaccination
policies um that are
mandatory okay whether it's Co or
otherwise all right thank thank you for
that
clarification further questions from the
committee seeing none n representative
camell thank you Mr chair um I have to
disagree with that I was a kidney
transplant patient still I still am up
at Dartmouth Hitchcock and in order to
get the kidney transplant I had to take
a multitude of vaccinations some of
which I didn't want to take but I had to
take them so unless you've reversed that
policy in the last couple of months the
the statement you just made I don't
believe would you like to readdress that
statement I I would I stand by the
statement which is with with respect
to the reever there was a reversal of
the policy that required a covid
vaccination a thorough review of policy
has been done between the our senior
leadership and clinical teams to that I
can clear clearly state that there is
not a policy of of requirement for care
for any vaccine do we encourage vaccines
absolutely do we strongly encourage
vaccines
absolutely further from the
committee thank you for your testimony
we'll next hear from Ben Bradley New
Hampshire hospital associate
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is Ben
Bradley I'm the vice president of state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association we
represent all 26 hospitals uh acute care
hospitals in New Hampshire as well as
all specialty hospitals um we do have
concerns about the proposed non-main
amendment
102h uh and particularly as it relates
to the implementation of
intention excuse
me following Matthew's comments I would
Echo his comments about supporting the
patient Bill of Rights and his questions
about enforcement and wonder if uh
enforcement should be reviewed
collaboratively uh it's unclear how a VI
under this bill under this amendment
it's unclear how a violation triggers
the prohibition for the Department to
contract is there an opportunity for
corrective action before uh it gets
triggered um and I guess we would
question how does prohibiting the
Department of Health and Human Services
from Contracting with the hospital in
violation of the patient Bill of Rights
help ensure that those patient rights
are restored in those
circumstances additionally if no other
entity in the state is capable of
fulfilling uh that contract um then what
happens to those Services um I can't
give a broad picture of all the contract
TR s that the state has with our members
but I can tell you things like uh
services at New Hampshire hospital
services at Hamstead Hospital the
doorways program that I believe seven of
our members uh operate and serve the
communities with um all those are
programs that are contracted with the
state of New
Hampshire so if those contracts are
eliminated and somebody isn't able to um
uh support them in some other way if
there wasn't a capability from somebody
in state would the state of New
Hampshire be looking for a contract
entity from out of state and how does
that contracted entity comply with New
Hampshire's Patient Bill of Rights when
they're an out of state entity that's
not licensed in New
Hampshire
um so uh for these reasons uh we we
can't support the non-gain amendment uh
but I'm happy to take questions as best
I can thank you question
committee represent
string so has any Hospital uh to your
knowledge been found of any violation of
any section of RSA
15121 you including any you know single
of that fairly long Patient Bill of
Rights not that I'm aware
of followup follow up if they if they
were going to be found in violation who
would have who would have done that how
would have that been brought up and how
would it be adjudicated uh based on
current law to your experience yeah I'm
not a legal expert so I I can't really
speak to that because I don't know the
enforcement mechanism uh other than what
Matthew had previously stated which was
a um a court process to to file
suit represent tki for a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so you alluded to one of my
questions previously but I just want to
make sure that I'm understanding so we
heard um that Dartmouth has 36,000
Medicaid patients we know they have
contracts with New Hampshire hospital
Hamstead Hospital Etc would you say that
if um Dartmouth but or if any of the
other um hospitals that are providers in
the state um found that they were in
violation which would trigger we're not
sure what the enforcement would be but
and I was we were told that it's not
backwards looking but forwards looking
but let's just say um a contract was
nullified would you say that that could
Implement a possible healthare crisis in
a region of the state based on um the
services that a hospital provides I
think that's to be determined um if you
look back at the applications for
various contracts with the Department of
Health and Human Services I think an
indicator may be how many entities
actually applied for those contracts and
bid for those contracts if there was one
entity that happened to be one Hospital
that it bid for those contracts I'd be
concerned that there wasn't a backup
plan and that may be an indicator from
the historic applications for those
contracts if that makes sense so if you
look back on who's bid for various
contracts with the state and you see
that only one entity has bid for that
because that one entity is the only
entity in the state of New Hampshire
that is capable of meeting the
expectations of that contract it would
be concerning to to completely eliminate
it um it may be one I guess what I would
also say is process is really what I'm
questioning is how is this determined
how is this
enforced um uh is there a
remediation uh process where you could
have a corrective action to prevent an
entity from losing a contract with the
state of New Hampshire now if it's
forward-looking then I assume which is a
little bit unclear to me uh but if it is
forward-looking you would assume that
all contracts that currently exists are
grandfathered despite the intent here of
saying you you can no longer contract so
all those contracts are now
grandfathered and if there's a patient
uh Bill of Rights violation then this
would not be triggered so I'm just
trying to make sense of how this plays
out in practical
reality I understand the intention here
is to hold hospitals accountable I just
wonder if there's a a measured approach
that doesn't prevent hospitals from
serving the communities quick follow
that need their services thank you for
that perspective um but looking at the
language we don't have specific language
that says anything's grandfathered and
it's only forward-looking or anything
like that as far as you can read not
that I can read no and and here's the
thing I mean we're willing to you know
look at this and make sure members are
in compliance I think the Department of
Health and Human Services May provide
some perspective on when they hear
complaints or how how this all plays out
but um do have some outstanding concerns
with this Bill thank
you
representative SE seaworth and then
representative Naval Len thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony thank you represent are you
aware of in existing
contracts is there Lang language within
them that requires compliance with state
law as a condition of of the contract
it's a it's a very good question and I
would yield to the Department of Health
and Human Services as to whether that's
a required expectation in their
contracts and how they would handle a
violation of that provision of their
contracts thank you representative Neno
Neno aleno um thank you for taking the
questions so if I understand you uh
correctly and I and and I probably might
agree to some extent that they're a
process your focus was on process issues
so my question is would uh your
organization be willing to work with the
committee to uh sort out the process
questions really you know may not be a
simple matter but most contracts I think
contain some of the issues that was were
raised by representative Murray and
those are eminently fixable is is this
something that you'd be you know beyond
the process questions would be willing
to work with the committee to sort out
the process questions and would that be
uh uh make this acceptable yeah I'm
always available to work with the
committee I think what this what
addressed that is accountability and I I
would agree that some you know there are
certain issues that are raised by other
members of the committee that are
processed related questions and and
language questions and I'm assuming uh
those could be sorted out in a manner
that's consistent with what basic
contract
law I I I'd be happy to share any
perspective and get feedback from our
membership thank you thank you
representative representative priest
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh I'm concerned
about the unintended consequences of
this amendment to the healthc care
providers and those who are getting the
services um and I would love to see some
quick analysis of how many contracts are
out there how many people are served
what if we took a drastic approach and
said you have to live this by the letter
of the law and there are no um
remediation or no process on this like
like we're seeing now with the executive
Council by not awarding contracts I mean
I would like to know what the impacts
are going to be to this state and to the
people who are needing these Services is
that something that you could look at so
I would just respond a couple ways thank
you representative for the question the
first is um I think as stated by others
who have provided testimony the hope is
that this wouldn't have to
be a measure that gets triggered and we
are committed to our members are
committed to the patient Bill of Rights
however we do have to look at the as you
mentioned the consequences that are
intentionally laid out in this non-gain
amendment should those circumstances
trigger a Prohibition for the Department
of Health and Human Services not to
contract not be allowed to contract cont
with the hospital to provide
services um with respect to my
involvement in reviewing the um the Imp
the potential impact the hypothetical
impact of this bill I'm available and
would be happy to work with the
committee or anybody else however I also
think that you could go to the source of
these contracts which is the Department
of Health and Human Services to get a
full understanding and accounting of
what contracts they have with Hospital
licensed under RSA
151 thank
you all right I see I have a card here
from somebody that deals with DHHS
contracts and maybe they can answer some
of your questions if there's no further
questions for this witness thank you Mr
chair thank you so we'll call on Robert
Moore says he's representing DHHS
contracts thank you for coming and
helping us out
yeah good afternoon for the record
Robert Moore I'm the contracts director
at the Department of Health and Human
Services um first the Department's not
taking a position on this bill but I did
want to attempt to answer some of the
questions that came up earlier um namely
around the number of contracts that the
department currently has with hospitals
and this is just a rough count we can
get you a complete list of these
contracts um later we have somewhere
between um 23 to 24 active contracts
with six to7 hospitals and as referenced
earlier those includes some of our
Psychiatric Services and neurology
services at New Hampshire hospital um
Regional public health networks a wide
range of services with various hospitals
throughout the
state questions for this
witness representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my questions of those 2324
contracts how many people are being
served and how many people would lose
this service if suddenly somebody
claimed that you were not in compliance
and therefore the contract would be void
it really varies greatly by the contract
I don't have those numbers uh with me
today but I can C we can certainly pull
those numbers together thank
you representative rung for a question
then represent thank you Mr chair um and
thank you mren for taking my question um
I I actually have two you said that DHHS
has 23 to 24 contracts with 67
hospitals excuse me 6 to7 Hospital six
to S I'm sorry okay so I'm assuming most
of the hospitals in New Hampshire don't
have any contracts with DHHS so this
wouldn't impact them um in terms of the
actual so I want to make a distinction
between you know Medicaid providers
providing Medicaid services and then the
hospitals that we're actively
Contracting with so that would be a
minority of the hospital 6 to seven
hospitals oh okay and followup Mr chair
um what um are there other dep
departments that you're aware of in or
other other areas of the state of state
government that provide contracts to
hospitals besides DHHS I believe there
would be other agencies that um may have
contracts with hospitals off the top of
my head I couldn't cite those um but we
could look into that as well okay thank
you representative Ms for a question
thank you Mr whoa thank you Mr chair and
uh thank you for taking my question um
those those 23 or 24 contracts that you
mentioned do they do they have language
in those contracts right now that
addresses um uh that includes a
requirement to be in compliance with the
patient Bill of Rights and does it and
and are there enforcement mechanisms in
those in that contract as well yes so
all state contracts um have uh what's
called a form p37 so those are standard
terms and conditions of all state
contracts the department of health uses
those there's a provision in there that
contractors are agreeing to um comply
with all applicable state federal local
laws and regulations um should a
contractor be in violation with that
provision uh we would consider that an
event an event of default um and there
are also uh corrective action steps that
we would take to work with the
contractor to remedy it remedy that um
that are articulated in the contract as
well a quick so quick followup um so
given that that language already exists
it it to me it sounds like the intent of
this amendment is already addressed in
the existing contracts that we have
would that be a fair statement um I I
think I would defer to this committee uh
to to make that assessment as I said the
Department's not taking a position on
that but um there are I can say there
are um requirements within all of our
contracts that all contractors have to
comply with state law um and there are
steps outlined in those contracts that
we we would take to work with that
contractor to remedy that should they
not remedy um those those events of
default uh within the period um as
required by the department um we would
take steps to then uh potentially
terminate that
contract further questions who was first
here restive Campell thank you Mr chair
so just um question in this particular
case that just occurred recently with
tcock did HHS take any corrective action
to help that
patient um I as the contract director I
wasn't involved in that that's that's
not within my purview um I my
understanding is the Department of
Justice was working closely with um
Dartmouth to uh remedy that um but we
could I could certainly take that back
to the team the focuses on that and get
you those details followup yes thank you
for the followup so it doesn't seem like
the system's working you just you know
you laid out a very nice um process of
how it's supposed to work when there's a
violation and HHS has those contracts
why wasn't HHS involved before you had
to go to the Department of Justice I I
can't again I can't speak to D Justice
involvement because that's not within
the purview of the contracts Bureau in
terms of what steps or what um
involvement the department had up to
that
point representative tki for thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you for taking my
question um you spoke specifically about
um six to seven hospitals that currently
have contracts with the state that's
correct but previously in this hearing
um we were discussing um and it was
referred to the fact that every hospital
that takes Medicaid patients have a
contract with the state so based on that
information I'm trying to figure out how
this amendment the language of this
amendment actually applies if you
believe that this would apply to every
single hospital that takes medic a
patients or do you think that it's
written to just mean an additional
contract that a hospital has with the
state perhaps Hamstead hospital or other
services um I would take this to mean um
hospitals that we actively have a
contract with which are again a
distinction made between those hospitals
we contract with and then those
hospitals that are Medicaid
providers okay so there we I would not
consider those be contractors um in
terms of contractors that sign hospitals
that sign our p37 contract okay that's
what I thought thank
you represent hack and Phillips thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Mo for
taking my question um just to follow
along the lines of my colleague's
earlier question about the actual uh
language in current existing contracts
um I I'm assuming that these contracts
also have kind of standard waiver notice
and acceleration Clauses as
well um can you can you explain a little
more what you mean exactly by your
interpretation default upon a default
that the state would have the option to
to wave additional notice and to
accelerate you know their remedies
essentially yeah there are a number of
steps we can take up up until um one
notice of of the event of default um
articulating what the corrective action
is the cure period in order to remedy
that corrective action all the way up to
termination should should that be
necessary great thank you further
questions representative Rong thank you
Mr chair it just came to my mind that in
the language of the amendment it says
the department shall not contract with
any Hospital found in violation so do
you take that to mean that the
department would never be able to
contract with that hospital again if
they were found in violation because it
says shall not
contract um I think so that question
that's that's a great question thank you
for the question um I I guess I would
defer to the committee in terms of how
that's been interpreted um I think that
question's been raised in terms of
seeking Clarity on that um so we I mean
I'm I'm sort of here to Monitor and and
better understand how how the department
could comply with this as written thank
you
yeah anything further for the
witness seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you
is there anyone else that would like to
testify on this either 519 or the
proposed
amendment seeing
none nobody on the blue
sheet the uh remote people that have
have signed in um for the house bill
519 it doesn't say for the amendment it
says supported by 35 opposed by three
neutral for zero so we have some input
on this we have some input from our
Witnesses and this will be again
discussed next Tuesday at time did I say
one
o'clock
um Mr 10 o'cl 10 o'clock clarification
Mr chairman sorry so this will not come
to division three for a more in-depth
discussion
well it came from division three the
amendment the the amendment where
is he's
out represent
Edwards his uh urgency to me before this
thing was he wanted it to get to the
house as soon as possible so that there
would be a vote on the amendment so the
amendment basically replaces
519 well we would have to re he it
actually doesn't so I just wondering if
we were going to have a work session or
not but you're stating that we're not
having a work session he he didn't
indicate to me prior to this that he
planned a work session I told him we
were having an exact session do you want
it to be on it yes I want it to get
before the house as soon as possible
so that's that's where we sit we will we
will be exacting tomorrow
as I said next next week
so that's when we'll have further
discussion on it I believe may be
lengthy but because of trying to stick
with what the division one division 3
chair gave me as his plan and now he's
not here to make any further comment so
with what we agreed to earlier that's
what it was thank you for your attention
okay
so um let's see we don't have any you
have any division chairs here to tell us
anything for the rest of the week I
guess not so I think probably Division
division one's probably going to keep
meeting representative priest uh point
of clarification Mr chairman um division
three has not taken a position on the
bill we've discussed it but we have not
taken a formal position and we have
again we have not discussed this
amendment I agree with you but this was
the uh I did not have the impression
that you this was the first time you've
seen
it it is in fact I'm sorry about that
but the discussions I had with the chair
division 3 said I want to get this to
the house as soon as
possible um it replaces the bill but I'm
still taking care of Waypoint within the
body of the budget which is something
we've done before and normally you'll
see most of the bills that we' come
before us will be um retained and then
we'll do our best to Endeavor to put
them in the budget bill and the people
that have those bills will come before
us when we make the presentation say hey
what happened to my bill we'll say yes
it's been Incorporated and then since we
do retain them some decision has to be
made this next fall so normally we come
before we bring all those retain bills
before us we go down the list this has
been included this has been included
this has been included this has been
included this was not included because
we didn't agree to it and and we do away
with all the bills that we've retained
at that point because we've done some
action with them within the budget
that's the traditional way we do it I'm
sorry that this seems to be hastened I
had thought from his discussion with me
that perhaps those of you on division
three had had some discussion on it I
apologize but that's so far what I've
scheduled for it if he decides to have a
work session in the interim I'll have
him contact you as we've got a week can
I just ask a quick clarification so that
means that it'll come to full Finance
without a recommendation from division
three that's
process-wise Mr Ripple or that is what
would happen I just briefly talked to
representative Edwards a few minutes ago
he said there will probably be a
division 3 work session on this before
the full Finance meeting so I'll I'll
confirm with him and try to schedule
something maybe for this Friday very
good all right so that's that's the
latest we have thank you so possibly be
be aware and be ready for something on
Friday so anything further come before
us I don't know if there's uh probably
division one meets
tomorrow Vice chair does anybody anybody
know in division one no we don't we
don't meet you're not meeting all right
so
we'll see everybody Thursday Mr chair I
have a question about
Friday do we have any estimate for how
long the presentation will be on Friday
afternoon give me the question again uh
I'm just wondering about Friday
afternoon with the governor um do we
have any idea or estimate of how long
the unless he shared it with with Mr
Ripple he didn't share anything with me
for for this
Friday I've got FIS on Friday this will
be in this this room at 11:00 for fiscal
and then I have down division one at
1:15
okay representative Edwards we have a
lot of questions about the fact that
your your division members would like to
see a work session on this
bill I I I'm I I think we can work
session this bill um I I didn't think
this was controversial um I'm surprised
that it is as controversial as it is but
um rather than ask you to put it on to
exact next week I'll work with my LBA Mr
Ripple to to do a routine scheduling so
division 3 has another work
session um before we bring it back uh I
I don't I don't know if you would want
to just take it straight into an exec
after division three does one more work
session on it or not I I I think it
should be ready people will either know
yes or no at that
point okay Friday is available um not
this room pretty much because let's see
what we got here and then it's always
the calendaring issue we're early enough
to get it into the calendar yes you if
you want to hold a meeting this Friday
and so you could uh execute out in full
Finance next week we could try to make
something work
uh and it would get in the calendar um
the limitation on Friday is the governor
does present to the full finance
committee at 2:30 but we could try to do
something before
that Y and we're hoping to have a a
republican caucus at 1:00 on
Friday okay so um the Republicans were
no we're trying to caucus as a full
committee on one at 1:00 right correct
so um
then try in the
morning can the morning of the 14th I'm
I'm looking at division three people for
work session is it is that when fiscal
meets I just wanted to get clarity on
the process because there would not be a
recommendation from our division going
into the exec session on Tuesday which
is why I was asking about the work
session and since we haven't seen the
final amendment I I I think that's a
fair question and I'm just trying to
coordinate
it do do we have a fiscal I don't think
we
have pardon me that's the next week okay
then the governor comes here at 2:30 for
the budget right but so my morning is
free then the morning is free so I I
propose we do 10:00 Friday uh the 14th
work session division three on the non
gerain
Amendment all right is everybody here
from division three or if will get
notice of it
because it's it's no time to get it in
the calendar representative walner um is
obviously not here so I will text her I
can't confirm anything but 10 a.m. on
Friday is what you're suggesting she's
the only member missing so far
okay I appreciate your texting thank
you Mr chair can I try again to ask my
question about the 2:30 meeting with the
governor here in Finance on Friday do we
have an estimate for the amount of time
that her office plans to present present
to us we don't thank you and normally
it's it's the governor will be here a
short time maybe half an hour and then
would leave the uh budget director here
to answer questions for as long as it
takes so um that's generally the way
we've been doing it and I don't know how
lengthy that my guess would be they'd
all get tired of it in an hour an hour
and a
half representative m m Mr chair uh I
apologize if I missed this when I was uh
when I stepped away but is there any
sense of what the schedule for next week
is going to look
like so we're talking
about Monday Monday the 17th holiday
that's a
holiday
um Tuesday is when I had the exact
session scheduled the
18th Wednesday I believe
um division one will meet on
Wednesday and the session on Thursday
the
20th and fiscal is going to meet on
Friday the 21st which involves some of
us here but division one will meet that
afternoon
21st probably at 1:15 I think is
scheduled um on the
18th the exec is at
10: and that's full Finance that's all
of us that's all of us yep full
committee uh Tuesday the 18th 10:00 full
committee
exec I appreciate you all being here and
I know some of you had to run out to do
a committee or a a bill presentation and
so on but that's the way it
goes and uh you know I I appreciate that
you're all want to be very thoroughly
involved in this because this is tricky
we didn't really get any straight
answers about this contract stuff did we
anybodys hear it well we got this we got
of that maybe this maybe that and Jose
has personal experience that he was
forced to take the
shot to get his treatment so you know
obviously they were kind of overlooking
this and and also distressed by the fact
that covid we're now hearing more and
more negatives about it and you know and
and it's not being pushed as much as it
was because they admitted it wasn't a
vaccine it did not it did not prevent as
a vaccine
should and people that are getting the
uh the boosters I don't think it's
helping much either but yes sir may I
comment on that sir I I think the health
Community uh to to include the folks at
the CDC still call it a vaccine and I've
talked to them about they re the damage
they've done to the word vaccine um and
they understand that but they they they
still considered a
vaccine Yeah by redefining
it further thing I appreciate your
attendance I appreciate all your good
work for the for the budget we'll really
get busy in the following week
thank
you we are this we are in adjournment